[CLICK]
DAVID SONTAG: So welcome
to spring 2019 Machine
Learning for Healthcare.
My name is David Sontag.
I'm a professor in
computer science.
Also I'm in the Institute
for Medical Engineering
and Science.
My co-instructor today
will be Pete Szolovits,
who I'll introduce more towards
the end of today's lecture,
along with the rest
of the course staff.
So the problem.
The problem is that healthcare
in the United States
costs too much.
Currently, we're spending
$3 trillion a year,
and we're not even necessarily
doing a very good job.
Patients who have
chronic disease
often find that these chronic
diseases are diagnosed late.
They're often not managed well.
And that happens even
in a country with some
of the world's best clinicians.
Moreover, medical
errors are happening
all of the time,
errors that if caught,
would have prevented
needless deaths,
needless worsening
of disease, and more.
And healthcare
impacts all of us.
So I imagine that almost
everyone here in this room
have had a family member,
a loved one, a dear friend,
or even themselves suffer
from a health condition which
impacts your quality of
life, which has affected
your work, your
studies, and possibly
has led to a needless death.
And so the question that we're
asking in this course today
is how can we use
machine learning,
artificial intelligence, as
one piece of a bigger puzzle
to try to transform healthcare.
So all of us have
some personal stories.
I myself have
personal stories that
have led me to be
interested in this area.
My grandfather, who had
Alzheimer's disease,
was diagnosed quite late
in his Alzheimer's disease.
There aren't good treatments
today for Alzheimer's, and so
it's not that I would
have expected the outcome
to be different.
But had he been
diagnosed earlier,
our family would have
recognized that many
of the erratic things
that he was doing
towards the later years of his
life were due to this disease
and not due to
some other reason.
My mother, who had multiple
myeloma, a blood cancer, who
was diagnosed five
years ago now,
never started treatment
for her cancer
before she died one year ago.
Now, why did she die?
Well, it was believed
that her cancer was still
in its very early stages.
Her blood markers that
were used to track
the progress of the cancer put
her in a low risk category.
She didn't yet have
visible complications
of the disease that
would, according
to today's standard
guidelines, require treatment
to be initiated.
And as a result, the belief
was the best strategy
was to wait and see.
But unbeknownst to her and
to my family, her blood
cancer, which was caused
by light chains which
were accumulating, ended
up leading to organ damage.
In this case, the light chains
were accumulating in her heart,
and she died of heart failure.
Had we recognized that her
disease was further along,
she might have
initiated treatment.
And there are now over 20
treatments for multiple myeloma
which are believed to have
life-lengthening effect.
And I can give you four
or five other stories
from my own personal
family and my friends,
where similar things
have happened.
And I have no doubt that
all of you have as well.
So what can we do about
it is the question
that we want to try to
understand in today's course.
And don't get me wrong.
Machine learning,
artificial intelligence,
will only be one
piece of the puzzle.
There's so many other
systematic changes
that we're going to have to
make into our healthcare system.
But let's try to understand
what those AI elements might be.
So let's start in
today's lecture
by giving a bit of a background
on artificial intelligence
and machine learning
in healthcare.
And I'll tell you why I think
the time is right now, in 2019,
to really start to make a
big dent at this problem.
And then I'll tell you about--
I'll give you a
few examples of how
machine learning is likely
to transform healthcare
over the next decade.
And of course we're
just guessing,
but this is really
guided by the latest
and greatest in research, a lot
of it happening here at MIT.
And then we'll close
today's lecture
with an overview of
what's different,
what's unique about machine
learning healthcare.
All of you have taken some
machine learning course
in the past, and so
you know the basics
of supervised prediction.
Many of you have studied
things like clustering.
And you're certainly
paying attention
to the news, where you
see news every single day
about Google,
Facebook, Microsoft's
latest advances in speech
recognition, computer vision,
and so on.
So what's really
different about trying
to apply these techniques
in the healthcare domain?
The answer is that there's
a huge amount of difference,
and there are a lot
of subtleties to doing
machine learning right here.
And we'll talk about
that throughout
the whole entire semester.
So to begin, this
isn't a new field.
Artificial intelligence in
medicine goes back to the 1970s
or sometime even in the '60s.
One of the earliest
examples of trying
to use artificial
intelligence for diagnosis
was this MYCIN system developed
at Stanford, where the goal was
try to identify bacteria
that might cause infection
and then to try to
guide what would
be the appropriate
therapy for that bacteria.
Now, it was found that this
algorithm, this machine
learning, this
simple AI algorithm
was able to propose a good
therapy in 69% of cases, which
at the time was better
than the best or very good
infectious disease experts.
Now, it also had some
other elements of it
which were quite interesting.
So those of you
who've been following
the latest in chat bots might
find this a little prescient.
So there's a dialog interface
where the computer says,
I am ready.
The computer clinician
responds, this
is a 26-year-old male patient.
The computer tests
its understanding
of what's going on.
It says, the age of
the patient is 26.
The sex of the patient is male.
The clinician writes,
five days ago,
he had respiratory
tract infections.
The computer asks
what is his name.
Joe.
The computer responds,
my understanding
is the name of the
patient is Joe.
Respiratory tract is one of
the symptoms the patient had.
Then the clinician
writes, a couple of days
before the admission,
he had malaise,
which is general tiredness.
And the computer
responds, please
give me a date of admission.
The clinician responds, March
12, 1979, and the computer
again confirms that it's
understood appropriately.
And this is the preface to
the later diagnostic stages.
So the ideas of how AI
can really impact medicine
have been around a long time.
Yet these algorithms
which have been
shown to be very effective,
even going back to the 1970s,
didn't translate
into clinical care.
A second example, oh so equally
impressive in its nature,
was work from the
1980s in Pittsburgh,
developing what is known as the
INTERNIST-1 or Quick Medical
Reference system.
This was now used not
for infectious diseases,
but for primary care.
Here one might ask, how
can we try to do diagnosis
at a much larger scale, where
patients might come in with one
of hundreds of
different diseases
and could report thousands of
different symptoms, each one
giving you some
view, noisy view,
into what may be going on
with a patient's health.
And at a high level, they
modeled this as something
like a Bayesian network.
It wasn't strictly
a Bayesian network.
It was a bit more
heuristic at the time.
It was later developed to be so.
But at a high level, there were
a number of latent variables
or hidden variables
corresponding
to different diseases
the patient might have,
like flu or pneumonia
or diabetes.
And then there were
a number of variables
on the very bottom, which were
symptoms, which are all binary,
so the diseases are
either on or off.
And here the symptoms are
either present or not.
And these symptoms can include
things like fatigue or cough.
They could also be things that
result from laboratory test
results, like a high
value of hemoglobin A1C.
And this algorithm would
then take this model,
take the symptoms that were
reported for the patient,
and try to do reasoning over
what action might be going on
with that patient, to figure
out what the differential
diagnosis is.
There are over 40,000 edges
connecting diseases to symptoms
that those diseases were
believed to have caused.
And this knowledge base, which
was probabilistic in nature,
because it captured the idea
that some symptoms would only
occur with some
probability for a disease,
took over 15 person
years to elicit
from a large medical team.
And so it was a lot of effort.
And even in going
forward to today's time,
there have been few similar
efforts at a scale as
impressive as this one.
But again, what happened?
These algorithms are not
being used anywhere today
in our clinical workflows.
And the challenges that
have prevented them
from being used
today are numerous.
But I used a word
in my explanation
which should really hint at it.
I used the word
clinical workflow.
And this, I think, is one
of the biggest challenges.
Which is that the
algorithms were designed
to solve narrow problems.
They weren't necessarily even
the most important problems,
because clinicians generally do
a very good job at diagnosis.
And there was a big gap between
the input that they expected
and the current
clinical workflow.
So imagine that you have
now a mainframe computer.
I mean, this was the '80s.
And you have a clinician who
has to talk to the patient
and get some information.
Go back to the computer.
Type in a structured
data, the symptoms
that the patient's reporting.
Get information back from
the computer and iterate.
As you can imagine, that takes a
lot of time, and time is money.
And unfortunately, it
prevents it from being used.
Moreover, despite the fact
that it took a lot of effort
to use it when outside of
existing clinical workflows,
these systems were also
really difficult to maintain.
So I talked about
how this was elicited
from 15 person years of work.
There was no machine
learning here.
It was called
artificial intelligence
because one tries to reason
in an artificial way,
like humans might.
But there was no learning
from data in this.
And so what that means is if
you then go to a new place,
let's say this was
developed in Pittsburgh,
and now you go to Los Angeles
or to Beijing or to London,
and you want to apply
the same algorithms,
you suddenly have to
re-derive parts of this model
from scratch.
For example, the prior
probability of the diseases
are going to be very
different, depending
on where you are in the world.
Now, you might want to
go to a different domain
outside of primary care.
And again, one has to spend
a huge amount of effort
to derive such models.
As new medicine
discoveries are made,
one has to, again,
update these models.
And this has been a huge
blocker to deployment.
I'll move forward to
one more example now,
also from the 1980s.
And this is now for a
different type of question.
Not one of how do you do
diagnosis, but how do you
actually do discovery.
So this is an example
from Stanford.
And it was a really
interesting case
where one took a
data-driven approach to try
to make medical discoveries.
There was a database of what's
called a disease registry
from patients with
rheumatoid arthritis, which
is a chronic disease.
It's an autoimmune
condition, where
for each patient, over a
series of different visits,
one would record,
for example, here
it shows this is
visit number one.
The date was January 17, 1979.
The knee pain, patient's knee
pain, was reported as severe.
Their fatigue was moderate.
Temperatures was 38.5 Celsius.
The diagnosis for this
patient was actually
a different autoimmune
condition called systemic lupus.
We have some laboratory test
values for their creatinine
and blood nitrogen,
and we know something
about their medication.
In this case, they were
on prednisone, a steroid.
And one has this data
at every point in time.
This almost certainly
was recorded on paper
and then later,
these were collected
into a computer format.
But then it provides
the possibility
to ask questions and
make new discoveries.
So for example, in
this work, there
was a discovery
module which would
make causal hypotheses
about what aspects
might cause other aspects.
It would then do
some basic statistics
to check about the
statistical validity
of those causal hypotheses.
It would then present
those to a domain expert
to try to check off does
this make sense or not.
For those that are accepted,
it then uses that knowledge
that was just
learned to iterate,
to try to make new discoveries.
And one of the main
findings from this paper
was that prednisone
elevates cholesterol.
That was published in the Annals
of Internal Medicine in 1986.
So these are all
very early examples
of data-driven approaches
to improve both medicine
and healthcare.
Now flip forward to the 1990s.
Neural networks started
to become popular.
Not quite the neural
networks that we're
familiar with in
today's day and age,
but nonetheless, they shared
very much of the same elements.
So just in 1990, there
were 88 published studies
using neural networks for
various different medical
problems.
One of the things that really
differentiated those approaches
to what we see in
today's landscape
is that the number of
features were very small.
So usually features which were
similar to what I showed you
in the previous slide.
So structured data
that was manually
curated for the purpose of
using in machine learning.
And there was nothing
automatic about this.
So one would have to have
assistants gather the data.
And because of that,
typically, there
were very small number of
samples for each study that
were used in machine learning.
Now, these models,
although very effective,
and I'll show you some examples
in the next slide, also
suffered from the same
challenges I mentioned earlier.
They didn't fit well
into clinical workflows.
It was hard to get enough
training data because
of the manual efforts involved.
And what the community found,
even in the early 1990s,
is that these algorithms
did not generalize well.
If you went through this huge
effort of collecting training
data, learning your model, and
validating your model at one
institution, and you then
take it to a different one,
it just works much worse.
OK?
And that really
prevented translation
of these technologies
into clinical practice.
So what were these different
domains that were studied?
Well, here are a few examples.
It's a bit small, so
I'll read it out to you.
It was studied in breast cancer,
myocardial infarction, which
is heart attack,
lower back pain,
used to predict
psychiatric length of stay
for inpatient, skin tumors,
head injuries, prediction
of dementia, understanding
progression of diabetes,
and a variety of other problems,
which again are of the nature
that we see about, we
read about in the news
today in modern
attempts to apply
machine learning in healthcare.
The number of training
examples, as mentioned,
were very few, ranging from
39 to, in some cases, 3,000.
Those are individuals, humans.
And the networks,
the neural networks,
they weren't completely
shallow, but they
weren't very deep either.
So these were the
architectures they
might be 60 neurons, then
7, and then 6, for example,
in terms of each of the
layers of the neural network.
By the way, that
sort of makes, sense
given the type of data
that was fed into it.
So none of this is new,
in terms of the goals.
So what's changed?
Why do I think that
despite the fact
that we've had
what could arguably
be called a failure for
the last 30 or 40 years,
that we might actually have
some chance of succeeding now.
And the big differentiator, what
I'll call now the opportunity,
is data.
So whereas in the
past, much of the work
in artificial intelligence in
medicine was not data driven.
It was based on trying to elicit
as much domain knowledge as one
can from clinical
domain experts.
In some cases, gathering
a little bit of data.
Today, we have an
amazing opportunity
because of the prevalence of
electronic medical records,
both in the United
States and elsewhere.
Now, here the United States,
for example, the story
wasn't that way,
even back in 2008,
when the adoption of
electronic medical records
was under 10% across the US.
But then there wasn't an
economic disaster in the US.
And as part of the economic
stimulus package, which
President Obama initiated, there
was something like $30 billion
allocated to
hospitals purchasing
electronic medical records.
And this is already
a first example
that we see of
policy being really
influential to create the--
to open the stage
to the types of work
that we're going to be able
to do in this course today.
So money was then made available
as incentives for hospitals
to purchase electronic
medical records.
And as a result, the adoption
increased dramatically.
This is a really old number
from 2015 of 84% of hospitals,
and now today, it's
actually much larger.
So data is being collected
in an electronic form,
and that presents an opportunity
to try to do research on it.
It presents an opportunity
to do machine learning on it,
and it presents an opportunity
to start to deploy machine
learning algorithms,
where rather
than having to manually
input data for a patient,
we can just draw
it automatically
from data that's already
available in electronic form.
And so there are a
number of data sets
that have been made available
for research and development
in this space.
Here at MIT, there has
been a major effort
pioneered by Professor Roger
Mark, in the ECS and Institute
for Medical
Engineering department,
to create what's known as the
PhysioNet or Mimic databases.
Mimic contains data from
over 40,000 patients
and intensive care units.
And it's very rich data.
It contains basically
everything that's
being collected in the
intensive care unit.
Everything from notes that
are written by both nurses
and by attendings, to vital
signs that are being collected
by monitors that are
attached to patients,
collecting their blood pressure,
oxygen saturation, heart
rate, and so on,
to imaging data,
to blood test results as they're
made available, and outcomes.
And of course also
medications that are
being prescribed as it goes.
And so this is a wealth
of data that now one
could use to try
to study, at least
study in a very narrow
setting of an intensive care
unit, how machine learning
could be used in that location.
And I don't want to
under-emphasize the importance
of this database, both
through this course
and through the broader field.
This is really the
only publicly available
electronic medical
record data set
of any reasonable size
in the whole world,
and it was created here at MIT.
And we'll be using
it extensively
in our homework
assignments as a result.
There are other data sets that
aren't publicly available,
but which have been
gathered by industry.
And one prime example is the
Truven Market Scan database,
which was created by a
company called Truven, which
was later acquired by
IBM, as I'll tell you
about more in a few minutes.
Now, this data-- and there are
many competing companies that
have similar data sets--
is created not from
electronic medical records,
but rather from--
typically, it's created
from insurance claims.
So every time you
go to see a doctor,
there's usually
some record of that
that is associated to the
billing of that visit.
So your provider will send a
bill to your health insurance
saying basically what
happened, so what procedures
were performed,
providing diagnoses
that are used to justify
the cost of those procedures
and tests.
And from that data, you
now get a holistic view,
a longitudinal view,
of what's happened
to that patient's health.
And then there is
a lot of money that
passes behind the scenes
between insurers and hospitals
to corporate companies,
such as Truven,
which collect that
data and then resell it
for research purposes.
And one of the biggest
purchasers of data like this
is the pharmaceutical industry.
So this data, unfortunately, is
not usually publicly available,
and that's actually a big
problem, both in the US
and elsewhere.
It's a big obstacle to
research in this field,
that only people who
have millions of dollars
to pay for it really
get access to it,
and it's something that
I'm going to return to
throughout the semester.
It's something
where I think policy
can make a big difference.
But luckily, here
at MIT, the story's
going to be a bit different.
So thanks to the MIT
IBM Watson AI Lab,
MIT has a close
relationship with IBM.
And fingers crossed, it
looks like we'll get access
to this database for our
homework and projects
for this semester.
Now, there are a lot
of other initiatives
that are creating
large data sets.
A really important
example here in the US
is President Obama's
Precision Medicine Initiative,
which has since been renamed
to the All of Us Initiative.
And this initiative
is creating a data set
of one million patients, drawn
in a representative manner,
from across the United
States, to capture
patients both poor and rich,
patients who are healthy
and have chronic disease,
with the goal of trying
to create a research
database where
all of us and other people,
both inside and outside the US,
could do research to
make medical discoveries.
And this will include
data such as data
from a baseline health exam,
where the typical vitals are
taken, blood is drawn.
It'll combine data of
the previous two types
I've mentioned,
including both data
from electronic medical records
and health insurance claims.
And a lot of this work is
also happening here in Boston.
So right across the street
at the Broad Institute,
there is a team
which is creating
all of the software
infrastructure
to accommodate this data.
And there are a large
number of recruitment sites
here in the broader
Boston area where
patients or any one of you,
really, could go and volunteer
to be part of this study.
I just got a letter in the mail
last week inviting me to go,
and I was really
excited to see that.
So all sorts of
different data is
being created as a
result of these trends
that I've been mentioning.
And it ranges from unstructured
data, like clinical notes,
to imaging, lab
tests, vital signs.
Nowadays, what we used to think
about just as clinical data
now has started to
really come to have
a very tight tie to what we
think about as biological data.
So data from genomics
and proteomics
is starting to play a major
role in both clinical research
and clinical practice.
Of course, not everything
that we traditionally
think about healthcare data--
there are also some
non-traditional views
on health.
So for example, social
media is an interesting way
of thinking through both
psychiatric disorders, where
many of us will post things
on Facebook and other places
about our mental
health, which give
a lens on our mental health.
Your phone, which is
tracking your activity,
will give us a view
on how active we are.
It might help us diagnose
early the variety of conditions
as well that I'll mention later.
So we have-- to this
whole theme right
now is about what's changed
since the previous approaches
at AI medicine.
I've just talked about
data, but data alone
is not nearly enough.
The other major
change is that there
has been decades' worth of work
on standardizing health data.
So for example, when I
mentioned to you that when
you go to a doctor's office,
and they send a bill,
that bill is associated
with a diagnosis.
And that diagnosis is coded in
a system called ICD-9 or ICD-10,
which is a standardized
system where,
for many, not all,
but many diseases,
there is a corresponding
code associated with it.
ICD-10, which was
recently rolled
out nationwide about a year
ago is much more detailed
than the previous
coding system, includes
some interesting categories.
For example, bitten by a
turtle has a code for it.
Bitten by sea lion,
struck by [INAUDIBLE]..
So it's starting to get
really detailed here,
which has its benefits and its
disadvantages when it comes
to research using that data.
But certainly, we can do
more with detailed data
than we could with
less detailed data.
Laboratory test results are
standardized using a system
called LOINC, here
in the United States.
Every lab test order has
an associated code for it.
I just want to point out briefly
that the values associated
with those lab tests
are less standardized.
Pharmacy, national drug codes
should be very familiar to you.
If you take any medication
that you've been prescribed,
and you look carefully,
you'll see a number on it,
and you see 0015347911, that
number is unique to that
medication.
In fact, it's even unique to
the brand of that medication.
And there's an associated
taxonomy with it.
And so one can really understand
in a very structured way what
medications a patient is on and
how those medications relate
to one another.
A lot of medical data is found
not in the structured form,
but in free text, in
notes written by doctors.
And these notes have,
often, lots of mentions
of symptoms and
conditions in them.
And one can try to
standardize those
by mapping them to what's called
a unified medical language
system, which is an
ontology with millions
of different medical
concepts in them.
So I'm not going to go
too much more into these.
They'll be the subject of much
discussion in this semester,
but particularly in the
next two lectures by Pete.
But I want to talk very briefly
about what you can do once you
have a standardized vocabulary.
So one thing you
can do is you could
build APIs, or Application
Programming Interfaces,
for now sending that
data from place to place.
And FHIR, F-H-I-R,
is a new standard,
which has widespread adoption
now here in the United States
for hospitals to provide data
both for downstream clinical
purposes but also
directly to patients.
And in this
standard, it will use
many of the
vocabularies I mentioned
to you in the previous slides to
encode diagnoses, medications,
allergies, problems, and
even financial aspects
that are relevant to the
care of this patient.
And for those of you who have
an Apple phone, for example,
and if you open up a
Apple Health Records,
it makes use of this
standard to receive data
from over 50
different hospitals.
And you should expect
to see many competitors
to them in the future,
because of the fact
that it's now an open standard.
Now other types of data,
like the health insurance
claims I mentioned
earlier, is often
encoded in a slightly
different data model.
One which my lab works quite
a bit with is called OMOP,
and it's being maintained by a
nonprofit organization called
the Observational Health Data
Sciences Initiative Odyssey.
And this common data
model gives a standard way
of taking data from
an institution which
might have its own intricacies
and really mapping it
to this common language, so that
if you write a machine learning
algorithm once, then
that machine learning
algorithm reads in
data in this format,
you can then apply it
somewhere else very easily.
And the portions
of these standards
really can't be
understated, the importance
for translating what
we're doing in this class
into clinical practice.
And so we'll be
returning to these things
throughout the semester.
So we've talked about data.
We've talked about standards.
And the third wheel
is breakthroughs
in machine learning.
And this should be no surprise
to anyone in this room.
All right, we've been
seeing time and time again,
over the last five years,
benchmark after benchmark being
improved upon and human
performance beaten
by state-of-the-art machine
learning algorithms.
Here I'm just
showing you a figure
that I imagine many
of you have seen,
on the error rates on the image
net competition for object
recognition.
The error rates
in 2011 were 25%.
And even just a few
years ago, it already
surpassed human
level to under 5%.
Now, the changes that have led
to those advances in object
recognition are going to have
some parallels in healthcare,
but only up to some point.
For example, there was big
data, large training sets
that were critical for this.
There were algorithmic
advances, in
particular convolutional
neural networks,
that played a huge role.
And there was open source
software that was created,
things like TensorFlow
and PyTorch,
which allow a researcher or
industry worker in one place
to very, very quickly
build upon successes
from other researchers
in other places
and then release the code,
so that one can really
accelerate the rate of
progress in this field.
Now, in terms of those
algorithmic advances that
have made a big
difference, the ones
that I would really
like to point out
because of their
relevance to this course
are learning with high
dimensional features.
So this was really the
advances in the early 2000s,
for example.
And support vector machines and
learning with L1 regularization
as a type of sparsity.
And then more recently,
in the last six years,
on stochastic gradient
descent, like methods
for very rapidly solving these
convex optimization problems,
that will play a
huge role in what
we'll be doing in this course.
In the last few
years, there have
been a huge amount
of progress in
unsupervised and semi-supervised
learning algorithms.
And as I'll tell you
about much later,
one of the major
challenges in healthcare
is that despite the fact that
we have a large amount of data,
we have very little
labeled data.
And so these semi-supervised
learning algorithms
are going to play a
major role in being
able to really take advantage
of the data that we do have.
And then of course the modern
deep learning algorithms.
Convolutional neural networks,
recurrent neural networks,
and ways of trying
to train them.
So those played a major
role in the advances
in the tech industry.
And to some extent, they'll
play a major role in healthcare
as well.
And I'll point out a
few examples of that
in the rest of today's lecture.
So all of this coming together,
the data availability,
the advances in other
fields of machine learning,
and the huge amount of potential
financial gain in healthcare
and the potential social
impact it could have
has not gone unnoticed.
And there's a huge
amount of industry
interested in this field.
These are just some examples
from names I think many of you
are familiar with, like
DeepMind Health and IBM Watson
to startup companies
like Bay Labs
and PathAI, which is here
in Boston, all of which
are really trying to build
the next generation of tools
for healthcare, now based on
machine learning algorithms.
There's been billions
of dollars of funding
in the recent quarters towards
digital health efforts,
with hundreds of
different startups
that are focused specifically
on using artificial intelligence
and healthcare.
And there's the
recognition that data
is so essential to
this process has
led to an all-out purchasing
effort to try to get as much
of that data as you can.
So for example, IBM
purchased a company
called Merge, which made
medical imaging software
and thus had accumulated a large
amount of medical imaging data
for $1 billion in 2015.
They purchased Truven
for $2.6 billion in 2016.
Flatiron Health, which
is a company in New York
City focused on oncology, was
purchased for almost $2 billion
by Roche, a pharmaceutical
company, just last year.
And there's several more
of these industry moves.
Again, I'm just tying to get you
thinking about what it really
takes in this field, and
getting access to data
is actually a really
important one, obviously.
So let's now move
on to some examples
of how machine learning
will transform healthcare.
To begin with, I want to really
lay out the landscape here
and define some language.
There are a number
of different players
when it comes to the
healthcare space.
They're us, patients, consumers.
They are the doctors
that we go to,
which you could think
about as providers.
But of course they're
not just doctors,
they're also nurses and
community health workers
and so on.
There are payers, which
provide the-- where there is--
these edges are really
showing relationships
between the different
players, so our consumers, we
often, either from our
job or directly from us,
we will pay premiums for a
health insurance company,
to a health insurance
company, and then
that health insurance company
is responsible for payments
to the providers to provide
services to us patients.
Now, here in the US, the
payers are both commercial
and governmental.
So many of you will know
companies like Cigna or Aetna
or Blue Cross, which
are commercial providers
of healthcare, of
health insurance,
but there are also
governmental ones.
For example, the Veterans
Health Administration
runs one of the biggest health
organizations in the United
States, servicing our
veterans from the department,
people who have retired from
the Department of Defense, which
has the one of
the second biggest
health systems, the
Defense Health Agency.
And that is an
organization where--
both of those
organizations, where
both the payer and the
provider are really one.
The Center for Medicare
and Medicaid Services
here in the US provides
health insurance
for all retirees in
the United States.
And also Medicaid, which
is run at a state level,
provides health insurance
to a variety of individuals
who would otherwise
have difficulty
purchasing or obtaining
their own health insurance.
And those are examples of
state-run or federally run
health insurance agencies.
And then internationally,
sometimes the lines
are even more blurred.
So of course in places
like the United Kingdom,
where you have a government-run
health system, the National
Health Service, you have the
same system both paying for
and providing the services.
Now, the reason why this
is really important for us
to think about
already in lecture one
is because what's so
essential about this field
is figuring out where the
knob is that you can turn
to try to improve healthcare.
Where can we deploy
machine learning algorithms
within healthcare?
So some algorithms are going
to be better run by providers,
others are going to be
better run by payers,
directly provided to patients,
and some all of the above.
We also have to think
about industrial questions,
in terms of what is it going to
take to develop a new product.
Who will pay for this product?
Which is again an
important question
when it comes to
deploying algorithms here.
So I'll run through a couple of
very high-level examples driven
from my own work, focused
on the provider space,
and then I'll bump up to
talk a bit more broadly.
So for the last
seven or eight years,
I've been doing a lot
of work in collaboration
with Beth Israel
Deaconess Medical
Center, across the river, with
their emergency department.
And the emergency department
is a really interesting
clinical setting, because
you have a very short period
of time from when a patient
comes into the hospital
to diagnose what's going on
with them, to initiate therapy,
and then to decide
what to do next.
Do you keep them
in the hospital?
Do you send them home?
If you-- for each
one of those things,
what should the most
immediate actions be?
And at least here in the US,
we're always understaffed.
So we've got limited resources
and very critical decisions
to make.
So this is one example
of a setting where
algorithms that are
running behind the scenes
could potentially really help
with some of the challenges I
mentioned earlier.
So for example, one could
imagine an algorithm which
builds on techniques
like what I mentioned
to you for an internist one
or quick medical reference,
try to reason about what's
going on with the patient based
on the data that's available
for the patient, the symptoms.
But the modern view of
this shouldn't, of course,
use binary indicators
of each symptom, which
have to be entered in manually,
but rather all of these things
should be
automatically extracted
from the electronic medical
record or listed as necessary.
And then if one could
reason about what's
going on with a patient,
we wouldn't necessarily
want to use it for a diagnosis,
although in some cases,
you might use it for
an earlier diagnosis.
But it could also be used for
a number of other more subtle
interventions, for
example, better triage
to figure out which patients
need to be seen first.
Early detection of adverse
events or recognition
that there might be some unusual
actions which might actually
be medical errors that you
want to surface now and draw
attention to.
Now, you could also
use this understanding
of what's going
on with a patient
to change the way
that clinicians
interact with patient data.
So for example, one can try
to propagate best practices
by surfacing clinical
decision support,
automatically triggering
this clinical decision
support for patients that you
think it might be relevant for.
And here's one
example, where it says,
the ED Dashboard, the Emergency
Department Dashboard decision
support algorithms
have determined
this patient may be eligible for
the atria cellulitis pathway.
Cellulitis is often
caused by infections.
Please choose from
one of the options.
Enroll in the pathway, decline--
and if you decline,
you must include
a comment for the reviewers.
Now, if you clicked on enroll
in the pathway, at that moment,
machine learning disappears.
Rather, there is a
standardized process.
It's an algorithm, but it's
a deterministic algorithm,
for how patients with cellulitis
should be properly managed,
diagnosed, and treated.
That algorithm comes
from best practices,
comes from clinicians coming
together, analyzing past data,
understanding what
would be good ways
to treat patients of this
type, and then formalizing
that in a document.
The challenge is that there
might be hundreds or even
thousands of these
best practices.
And in an academic
medical center, where
you have patients coming--
where you have medical
students or residents who
are very quickly rotating
through the system and thus
may not be familiar
with which are
the most appropriate clinical
guidelines to use for any one
patient in this institution.
Or if you go to a
rural site, where
this academic nature of
thinking through what
the right clinical guidelines
are is a little bit less
of the mainstream, everyday
activity, the question of which
one to use when is
very challenging.
And so that's where the
machine learning algorithms
can come in.
By reasoning about what's
going on with a patient,
you might have a
good guess of what
might be appropriate
for this patient,
and you use that to
automatically surface
the right clinical
decisions for a trigger.
Another example
is by just trying
to anticipate clinician needs.
So for example, if you think
that this patient might
be coming in for a psychiatric
condition, or maybe
you recognize that the
patient came in that triage
and was complaining
of chest pain,
then there might
be a psych order
set, which includes
laboratory test results that
are relevant for
psychiatric patients,
or a chest pain order set, which
includes both laboratory tests
and interventions, like aspirin,
that might be suggested.
Now, these are also examples
where these order sets are not
created by machine
learning algorithms.
Although that's something
we could discuss later
in the semester.
Rather, they're standardized.
But the goal of the
machine learning algorithm
is just to figure out
which ones to show when
directly to the clinicians.
I'm showing you
these examples to try
to point out that diagnosis
isn't the whole story.
Thinking through what are the
more subtle interventions we
can do with machine learning
and AI and healthcare
is going to be really
important to having the impact
that it could have.
So other examples, now a bit
more on the diagnosis style,
are reducing the need
for specialist consults.
So you might have
a patient come in,
and it might be really quick
to get the patient in front
of an X-ray to do a
chest X-ray, but then
finding the radiologist
to review that X-ray
could take a lot of time.
And in some places,
radiologist consults
could take days, depending on
the urgency of the condition.
So this is an area where
data is quite standardized.
In fact, MIT just
released last week
a data set of
300,000 chest x-rays
with associated labels on them.
And one could try to ask
the question of could we
build machine
learning algorithms
using the convolutional
neural network type
techniques that we've seen
play a big role in object
recognition to try
to understand what's
going on with this patient.
For example, in this
case, the prediction
is the patient has pneumonia,
from this chest X-ray.
And using those
systems, it could
help both reduce the load
of radiology consults,
and it could allow us to really
translate these algorithms
to settings which
might be much more
resource poor, for example,
in developing nations.
Now, the same
sorts of techniques
can be used for other
data modalities.
So this is an
example of data that
could be obtained from an EKG.
And from looking
at this EKG, one
can try to predict, does the
patient have a heart condition,
such as an arrhythmia.
Now, these types of
data used to just
be obtained when you go
to a doctor's office.
But today, they're
available to all of us.
For example, in Apple's most
recent watch that was released,
it has a single-lead
EKG built into it,
which can attempt to predict
if a patient has an arrhythmia
or not.
And there are a
lot of subtleties,
of course, around what it took
to get regulatory approval
for that, which we'll
be discussing later
in the semester, and how one
safely deploys such algorithms
directly to consumers.
And there, there are a
variety of techniques
that could be used.
And in a few lectures,
I'll talk to you
about techniques from
the '80s and '90s
which were based on trying
to signal processing,
trying to detect where are
the peaks of the signal,
look at a distance
between peaks.
And more recently, because
of the large wealth
of data that is
available, we've been
using convolutional neural
network-based approaches
to try to understand this
data and predict from it.
Yet another example
from the ER really
has to do with not how do we
care for the patient today,
but how do we get
better data, which
will then result
in taking better
care of the patient tomorrow.
And so one example
of that, which
my group deployed at
Beth Israel Deaconess,
and it's still running there
in the emergency department,
has to do with getting higher
quality chief complaints.
The chief complaint is
usually a very short,
two or three word quantity, like
left knee pain, rectal pain,
right upper quadrant,
RUQ, abdominal pain.
And it's just a
very quick summary
of why did the patient
come into the ER today.
And despite the fact
that it's so few words,
it plays a huge role in
the care of a patient.
If you look at the
big screens in the ER,
which summarize who are the
patients and on what beds,
they have the chief
complaint next to it.
Chief complaints are used as
criteria for enrolling patients
in clinical trials.
It's used as criteria for doing
retrospective quality research
to see how do we care for
patients in a particular type.
So it plays a very big role.
But unfortunately, the data
that we've been getting
has been crap.
And that's because
it was free text,
and it was sufficiently
high dimensional
that just attempting
to standardize it
with a big dropdown list,
like you see over here,
would have killed the
clinical workflow.
It would've taken
way too much time
for clinicians to try to
find the relevant one.
And so it just wouldn't
have been used.
And that's where some very
simple machine learning
algorithms turned out
to be really valuable.
So for example, we changed
the workflow altogether.
Rather than the chief
complaint being the first thing
that the triage nurse assigns
when the patient comes in,
it's the last thing.
First, the nurse takes the vital
signs, patient's temperature,
heart rate, blood
pressure, respiratory rate,
and oxygen saturation.
They talk to the patient.
They write up a 10-word or
30-word note about what's
going on with the patient.
Here it says, "69-year-old
male patient with severe
intermittent right
upper quadrant pain.
Began soon after eating.
Also is a heavy drinker."
So quite a bit of
information in that.
We take that.
We use a machine learning
algorithm, a supervised machine
learning algorithm in
this case, to predict
a set of chief
complaints now drawn
from a standardized ontology.
We show the five most likely
ones, and the clinician,
in this case, a nurse, could
just click one of them,
and it would enter
it into there.
We also allow the nurse to type
in part of a chief complaint.
But rather than just
doing a text matching
to find words that match
what's being typed in,
we do a contextual autocomplete.
So we use our
predictions to prioritize
what's the most likely chief
complaint that contains
that sequence of characters.
And that way it's
way faster to enter
in the relevant information.
And what we found
is that over time,
we got much higher
quality data out.
And again, this
is something we'll
be talking about in one of
our lectures in this course.
So I just gave you an
example, a few examples,
of how machine learning
and artificial tolerance
will transform the
provider space,
but now I want to
jump up a level
and think through not how
do we treat a patient today,
but how do we think about the
progression of a patient's
chronic disease over
a period of years.
It could be 10 years, 20 years.
And this question of how do
we manage chronic disease
is something which affects
all aspects of the healthcare
ecosystem.
It'll be used by
providers, payers,
and also by patients themselves.
So consider a patient with
chronic kidney disease.
Chronic kidney disease, it
typically only gets worse.
So you might start with
the patient being healthy
and then have some
increased risk.
Eventually, they have
some kidney damage.
Over time, they
reach kidney failure.
And once they reach
kidney failure,
typically, they need dialysis
or a kidney transplant.
But understanding when
each of these things
is going to happen for
patients is actually really,
really challenging.
Right now, we have one way
of trying to stage patients.
The standard approach
is known as the EGFR.
It's derived predominantly from
the patient's creatinine, which
is a blood test
result, and their age.
And it gives you a number out.
And from that
number, you can get
some sense of where the
patient is in this trajectory.
But it's really coarse
grained, and it's not
at all predictive about
when the patient is
going to progress to the
next stage of the disease.
Now, other conditions,
for example,
some cancers, like I'll
tell you about next,
don't follow that
linear trajectory.
Rather, patients' conditions
and the disease burden,
which is what I'm
showing you in the y-axis
here, might get worse,
better, worse again, better
again, worse again, and
so on, and of course
is a function of the
treatment for the patient
and other things that
are going on with them.
And understanding
what influences,
how a patient's disease
is going to progress,
and when is that
progression going to happen,
could be enormously valuable for
many of those different parts
of the healthcare ecosystem.
So one concrete example of
how that type of prediction
could be used would be in a
type of precision medicine.
So returning back to the
example that I mentioned
in the very beginning
of today's lecture
of multiple myeloma, which
I said my mother died of,
there are a large number
of existing treatments
for multiple myeloma.
And we don't really know which
treatments work best for whom.
But imagine a day where
we have algorithms
that could take what you
know about a patient at one
point in time.
That might include, for
example, blood test results.
It might include RNA
seq, which gives you
some sense of the
gene expression
for the patient,
that in this case
would be derived from a sample
taken from the patient's bone
marrow.
You could take that
data and try to predict
what would happen to a patient
under two different scenarios.
The blue scenario that
I'm showing you here,
if you give them treatment
A, or this red scenario here,
where you give them treatment
B. And of course, treatment A
and treatment B aren't
just one-time treatments,
but they're strategies.
So they're repeated
treatments across time,
with some intervals.
And if your algorithm says
that under treatment B,
this is what's going to
happen, then you might--
the clinician might think, OK.
Treatment B is probably
the way to go here.
It's going to long-term
control the patient's disease
burden the best.
And this is an example
of a causal question.
Because we want
to know how do we
cause a change in the
patient's disease trajectory.
And we can try to answer
this now using data.
So for example, one of the data
sets that's available for you
to use in your course projects
is from the Multiple Myeloma
Research Foundation.
It's an example of
a disease registry,
just like the disease registry
I talked to you about earlier
for rheumatoid arthritis.
And it follows
about 1,000 patients
across time, patients who
have multiple myeloma.
What treatments they're
getting, what their symptoms
are, and at a couple
of different stages,
very detailed biological
data about their cancer,
in this case, RNA seq.
And one could attempt to use
that data to learn models
to make predictions like this.
But such predictions
are fraught with errors.
And one of the things
that Pete and I will
be teaching in this
course is that there's
a very big difference between
prediction and prediction
for the purpose of
making causal statements.
And the way that you interpret
the data that you have,
when your goal is to
do treatment suggestion
or optimization, is going to
be very different from what
you were taught in your
introductory machine
learning algorithms class.
So other ways that we could try
to treat and manage patients
with chronic disease
include early diagnosis.
For example, patients
with Alzheimer's disease,
there's been some really
interesting results just
in the last few years, here.
Or new modalities altogether.
For example, liquid
biopsies that
are able to do early
diagnosis of cancer,
even without having to do a
biopsy of the cancer tumor
itself.
We can also think about how
do we better track and measure
chronic disease.
So one example shown
on the left here
is from Dina Katabi's lab
here at MIT and CSAIL,
where they've developed a
system called Emerald, which
is using wireless signals,
the same wireless signals
that we have in this room
today, to try to track patients.
And they can actually
see behind walls,
which is quite impressive.
So using this for
the signal, you
could install what looks
like just a regular wireless
router in an elderly
person's home,
and you could detect if
that elderly patient falls.
And of course if the patient
has fallen, and they're elderly,
it might be very hard
for them to get back up.
They might have broken
a hip, for example.
And one could then alert the
caregivers, maybe if necessary,
bring in emergency support.
And that could have a long-term
outcome for this patient which
would really help them.
So this is an example of what
I mean by better tracking
patients with chronic disease.
Another example
comes from patients
who have type 1 diabetes.
Type 1 diabetes, as
opposed to type 2 diabetes,
generally develops in
patients at a very early age.
Usually as children
it's diagnosed.
And one is typically managed by
having an insulin pump, which
is attached to a patient and
can give injections of insulin
on the fly, as necessary.
But there's a really challenging
control problem there.
If you give a patient too much
insulin, you could kill them.
If you give them
too little insulin,
you could really hurt them.
And how much insulin
you give them
is going to be a function
of their activity.
It's going to be a function
of what food they're eating
and various other factors.
So this is a question which the
control theory community has
been thinking through
for a number of years,
and there are a number of
sophisticated algorithms
that are present in
today's products,
and I wouldn't be surprised if
one or two people in the room
today have one of these.
But it also presents a really
interesting opportunity
for machine learning.
Because right now, we're
not doing a very good job
at predicting future
glucose levels, which
is essential to figure out
how to regulate insulin.
And if we had algorithms
that could, for example, take
a patient's phone, take
a picture of the food
that a patient is eating,
have that automatically
feed into an algorithm that
predicts its caloric content
and how quickly that'll
be processed by the body.
And then as a result
of that, think about
when, based on this patient's
metabolic system, when should
you start increasing insulin
levels and by how much.
That could have a huge
impact in quality of life
of these types of patients.
So finally, we've
talked a lot about how
do we manage healthcare,
but equally important
is about discovery.
So the same data
that we could use
to try to change the way that
algorithms are implemented
could be used to think through
what would be new treatments
and make new discoveries
about disease subtypes.
So at one point later
in the semester,
we'll be talking about
disease progression modeling,
and we'll talk about how to
use data-driven approaches
to discover different
subtypes of disease.
And on the left,
here, I'm showing you
an example of a really nice
study from back in 2008
that used a k-means
clustering algorithm
to discover subtypes of asthma.
One could also use
machine learning
to try to make discoveries about
what proteins, for example,
are important in
regulating disease.
How can we differentiate at a
biological level which patients
will progress quickly,
which patients
will respond to treatment.
And that of course will
then suggest new ways of--
new drug targets for new
pharmaceutical efforts.
Another direction also
studied here at MIT,
by quite a few labs, actually,
has to do with drug creation
or discovery.
So one could use machine
learning algorithms
to try to predict what
would a good antibody be
for trying to bind with
a particular target.
So that's all for my overview.
And in the remaining
20 minutes, I'm
going to tell you a
little bit about what's
unique about machine
learning in healthcare,
and then an overview
of the class syllabus.
And I do see that it says,
replace lamp in six minutes,
or power will turn off
and go into standby mode.
AUDIENCE: We have
that one [INAUDIBLE]..
DAVID SONTAG: Ah, OK.
Good.
You're hired.
If you didn't get into the
class, talk to me afterwards.
All right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID SONTAG: [LAUGHS] We hope.
So what's unique about
machine learning healthcare?
I gave you already
some hints at this.
So first, healthcare is
ultimately, unfortunately,
about life or death decisions.
So we need robust algorithms
that don't screw up.
A prime example of this, which
I'll tell you a little bit more
about towards the
end of the semester
is from a major software
error that occurred something
like 20, 30 years ago in a--
in an X-ray type
of device, where
an overwhelming
amount of radiation
was exposed to a patient just
because of a software overflow
problem, a bug.
And of course that resulted
in a number of patients dying.
So that was a software
error from decades ago,
where there was no machine
learning in the loop.
And as a result of that and
similar types of disasters,
including in the space industry
and airplanes and so on,
led to a whole area of
research in computer science
in formal methods and how do we
design computer algorithms that
can check that a
piece of software
would do what it's supposed
to do and would not make--
and that there
are no bugs in it.
But now that we're going to
start to bring data and machine
learning algorithms
into the picture,
we are really suffering
for lack of good tools
for doing similar formal
checking of our algorithms
and their behavior.
And so this is going
to be really important
in the future decade, as
machine learning gets deployed
not just in settings
like healthcare,
but also in other settings
of life and death,
such as in autonomous driving.
And it's something
that we'll touch on
throughout the semester.
So for example, when one deploys
machine learning algorithms,
we need to be thinking about
are they safe, but also
how do we check for
safety long-term?
What are checks and
balances that we
should put into the deployment
of the algorithm to make
sure that it's still
working as it was intended?
We also need fair and
accountable algorithms.
Because increasingly,
machine learning results
are being used to
drive resources
in a healthcare setting.
An example that I'll discuss
in about a week and a half,
when we talk about
risk stratification,
is that algorithms are
being used by payers
to risk stratify patients.
For example, to figure
out which patients
are likely to be readmitted
to the hospital in the next 30
days, or are likely
to have undiagnosed
diabetes, or are likely
to progress quickly
in their diabetes.
And based on those
predictions, they're
doing a number of interventions.
For example, they might send
nurses to the patient's home.
They might offer
their members access
to a weight loss program.
And each of these interventions
has money associated to them.
They have a cost.
And so you can't do
them for everyone.
And so one uses machine
learning algorithms
to prioritize who do you
give those interventions to.
But because health
is so intimately tied
to socioeconomic
status, one can think
about what happens if these
algorithms are not fair.
It could have really long-term
implications for our society,
and it's something that we're
going to talk about later
in the semester as well.
Now, I mentioned
earlier that many
of the questions that we
need to study in the field
don't have good label data.
In cases where we know
we want to predict,
there's a supervised
prediction problem,
often we just don't have
labels for that thing
we want to predict.
But also, in many
situations, we're
not interested in just
predicting something.
We're interested in discovery.
So for example, when I talk
about disease subtyping
or disease progression,
it's much harder
to quantify what
you're looking for.
And so unsupervised
learning algorithms
are going to be really
important for what we do.
And finally, I already mentioned
how many of the questions
we want to answer
are causal in nature,
particularly when
you want to think
about treatment strategies.
And so we'll have two
lectures on causal inference,
and we'll have two lectures on
reinforcement learning, which
is increasingly being
used to learn treatment
policies in healthcare.
So all of these
different problems
that we've talked about result
in our having to rethink how
do we do machine
learning in this setting.
For example, because
driving labels
for supervised
prediction is very hard,
one has to think through how
could we automatically build
algorithms to do what's
called electronic phenotyping
to discover, to figure
out automatically,
what is the relevant labels
for a set of patients
that one could then attempt
to predict in the future.
Because we often have
very little data,
for example, some
rare diseases, there
might only be a few
hundred or a few thousand
people in the nation
that have that disease.
Some common diseases
present in very diverse ways
and [INAUDIBLE] are very rare.
Because of that, you have just a
small number of patient samples
that you could get,
even if you had all
of the data in the right place.
And so we need to think through
how can we bring through--
how can we bring together
domain knowledge.
How can we bring together
data from other areas--
will everyone look
over here now--
from other areas,
other diseases,
in order to learn
something that then
we could refine for
the foreground question
of interest.
Finally, there is a ton of
missing data in healthcare.
So raise your hand
if you've only
been seeing your current
primary care physician
for less than four years.
OK.
Now, this was an easy
guess, because all of you
are students, and you
probably don't live in Boston.
But here in the US, even
after you graduate, you go out
into the world, you
have a job, and that job
pays your health insurance.
And you know what?
Most of you are going to
go into the tech industry,
and most of you are going to
switch jobs every four years.
And so your health
insurance is going
to change every four years.
And unfortunately,
data doesn't tend
to follow people when you
change providers or payers.
And so what that
means is for any one
thing we might want
to study, we tend
to not have very good
longitudinal data
on those individuals, at least
not here in the United States.
That story is a little bit
different in other places,
like the UK or
Israel, for example.
Moreover, we also
have a very bad lens
on that healthcare data.
So even if you've been going
to the same doctor for a while,
we tend to only have data on you
when something's been recorded.
So if you went to a doctor,
you had a lab test performed,
we know the results of it.
If you've never gotten
your glucose tested,
it's very hard,
though not impossible,
to figure out if you
might be diabetic.
So thinking about how
do we deal with the fact
that there's a large
amount of missing data,
where that missing data
has very different patterns
across patients, and
where there might
be a big difference between
train and test distributions
is going to be a major part of
what we discuss in this course.
And finally, the last
example is censoring.
I think I've said
finally a few times.
So censoring, which we'll
talk about in two weeks,
is what happens
when you have data
only for small windows of time.
So for example, you have a
data set where your goal is
to predict survival.
You want to know how
long until a person dies.
But a person-- you
only have data on them
up to January 2009,
and they haven't yet
died by January 2009.
Then that individual
is censored.
You don't know what
would have happened,
you don't know when they died.
So that doesn't mean you should
throw away that data point.
In fact, we'll
talk about learning
algorithms that can learn from
censored data very effectively.
So there are a number of also
logistical challenges to doing
machine learning in healthcare.
I talked about how having
access to data is so important,
but one of the reasons--
there are others--
for why getting large amounts
of data in the public domain
is challenging is because
it's so sensitive.
And removing identifiers,
like name and social,
from data which
includes free text notes
can be very challenging.
And as a result, when we
do research here at MIT,
typically, it takes us
anywhere from a few months--
which has never happened--
to two years, which
is the usual situation, to
negotiate a data sharing
agreement to get the health
data to MIT to do research on.
And of course then
my students write
code, which we're very happy to
open source under MIT license,
but that code is
completely useless,
because no one can reproduce
their results on the same data
because they don't
have access to it.
So that's a major
challenge to this field.
Another challenge is
about the difficulty
in deploying machine learning
algorithms due to the challenge
of integration.
So you build a good algorithm.
You want to deploy it at
your favorite hospital,
but guess what?
That hospital has Epic
or Cerner or Athena
or some other commercial
electronic medical records
system, and that electronic
medical records system
is not built for your
algorithm to plug into.
So there is a big
gap, a large amount
of difficulty to getting your
algorithms into production
systems, which we'll talk about
as well during the semester.
So the goals that Pete and I
have for you are as follows.
We want you to get intuition for
working with healthcare data.
And so the next two
lectures after today
are going to focus on what
healthcare is really like,
and what is the
healthcare data that's
created by the practice
of healthcare like.
We want you to get
intuition for how
to formalize machine learning
challenges as healthcare
problems.
And that formalization step
is often the most tricky
and something you'll spend
a lot of time thinking
through as part of
your problem sets.
Not all machine learning
algorithms are equally useful.
And so one theme
that I'll return to
throughout the semester
is that despite the fact
that deep learning is good
for many speech recognition
and computer vision problems,
it actually isn't the best match
to many problems in healthcare.
And you'll explore that also
as part of your problem sets,
or at least one of them.
And we want you to understand
also the subtleties in robustly
and safely deploying
machine learning algorithms.
Now, more broadly,
this is a young field.
So for example, just recently,
just about three years ago,
was created the first
conference on Machine Learning
in Healthcare, by that name.
And new publication venues are
being created every single day
by Nature, Lancet, and also
machine learning journals,
for publishing research on
machine learning healthcare.
Because it's one of those
issues we talked about,
like access to data, not
very good benchmarks,
reproducibility has
been a major challenge.
And this is again something that
the field is only now starting
to really grapple with.
And so as part of this
course, oh so many of you
are currently PhD students
or will soon be PhD students,
we're going to
think through what
are some of the challenges
for the research field.
What are some of
the open problems
that you might want to work
on, either during your PhD
or during your future career.